suzanne de serre à 60 ans musicienne
accomplie qui a joué un peu partout dans
le monde et il se considère comme une
force de la nature mais sa vie a basculé
l'été dernier j'ai été faire un tour de
kayak et là j'ai perdu la carte
complètement j'ai eu mal au coeur comme
mon corps vraiment qu'on veut c'est en
fait une résonance magnétique et ont vu
le tueur au cerveau et ont vu c'est à
guillaume la storm 2
même après avoir été opéré de cette
tumeur du cerveau le temps qu'il reste à
suzanne et maintenant comptés puisque
l'espérance de survie face au
glioblastome est en moyenne de 15 mois
j'avais comme une espèce d'urgence
et puis vous voyez si on a un bel
exemple j'ai un blanc total j'ai
complètement oublié la question m'avait
posé dans ma tête comme un téléphone et
des applications qui sont comme
débranché et l'on est témoin de ce je
suis témoin ne montera pas car le sommes
depuis sept mois celle qui a fait le
tour du monde grâce à sa musique et à
ses livres pour enfants se sent déjà
diminué ma vie créative est arrêté
présentement de penser imaginer une
histoire c'est un petit pot de mes
capacités
adam dessert la patiente est suivi par
l'institut de recherche du centre
universitaire de santé mcgill qui lui a
prodigué les séances de chimiothérapie
et de radiothérapie
un traitement qui n'a chez elle tout
comme chez 50 % des patients que peu
d'effet sur la tumeur
alors que la recherche n'a pas vraiment
fait de progrès depuis 15 ans l'équipe
du zoom pense avoir fait une percée dans
ce domaine en utilisant une molécule
laser 2002 pour traiter les patients
atteints du glioblastome tout le concept
de ce qu'on appelle de la cancérologie
standard c'est qu'il ya une seule cible
donc la cellule s'habitue à cette cible
à la développer des résistances
là elle n'a pas le temps on touche deux
mécanismes majeur le mécanisme de
défense des transmissions au niveau de
la membrane est notre adn qui est
essentiel pour la réplication et la
prolifération
ce qui est extrêmement important dans un
concert c'est la prolifération pour
guérir un concert il faut arrêter la
prolifération
cette grosse machine qu'on voit ici elle
est essentielle parce que ça permet de
voir un peu les progrès de votre
recherche
grâce à ses très imposant et coûteuse
équipements l'équipe de recherche a pu
démontrer que la molécule miracle est
capable de pénétrer le sang et de
rentrer dans la cellule tumorale cécile
un petit peu notre usine de production d
des molécules les résultats de cette
recherche vient d'être publiée dans le
journal cliniques locales seules
reasearch une découverte potentiellement
majeur mais qui n'intéresse pas
suffisamment l'industrie pharmaceutique
parce que comme toutes les maladies
orphelines c'est peu rentable à traiter
on a vingt sept de vos cas diagnostiqués
d'après le registre canadien chaque jour
ça peut toucher de la gêne en france
jusqu'à un âge très avancé
il n'y a pas l entrain de l'industrie
pharmaceutique de venir investir du
traitement très coûteux impuissante face
à cette tumeur virulente suzanne de
serre fonde tous ses espoirs sur cette
molécule
j'espère qu'elle me ce gamin de de
l'équipe de mcgill va vont intervenir
dans ma vie parce que parce que sinon il
se passe rien là c'est c'est la mort et
puis c'est pas intéressant de ce tour
mais financer des études cliniques
demande beaucoup d'argent si c'est un
peu le marathon pour être et pourrait se
trouver le fameux remet pour l'instant
la fondation de l'institut tentent
d'amasser un million trois cent mille
dollars pour avancer le projet jusqu'aux
prochaines phases sa ténacité des
millions $ et plusieurs années bien sûr
entre-temps dans le cadre d'études
cliniques des patients bénéficient donc
ça vaut absolument l'atteinte de
financer des études cliniques qui coince
social chrétien ces fameuses études
cliniques pour tester les nouveaux
traitements éric renaud essaye d'en
faire partie pour survivre le plus
longtemps
lui-même atteint du glioblastome à l'âge
de 41 ans il a participé à l'une d'entre
elles avec ce casque américain qui émet
des champs électriques sur le cerveau il
survit avec le glioblastome depuis
maintenant 10 ans ce qui est plutôt
exceptionnel talent aux etats-unis pour
dés à pignons différents puis
effectivement j'ai une autre pression
cette semaine suivante la première c'est
ce que je fais et façon régulière depuis
dix ans je regarde de façon régulière
les nouvelles études cliniques
est ce que vous direz que ça ses études
cliniques vous ne seriez plus là
aujourd'hui parce est sûre c'est ce pays
les globules ashton c'est une peine de
mort la dépouille
pour l'instant l'on vaut pas de
survivant alors je me compte chanceux ce
traitement qui n'est pas homologué au
canada et dont l'étude clinique est
terminée coûte environ trente et un
mille dollars par mois un montant
prohibitif pour les malades participer à
ce genre d'étude devient donc vital
c'est l'un des meilleurs arguments du
docteur abdoulkarim pour que ces
recherches soient financés ils ont
compris que sont les études cliniques et
papa rester en vie développer ici à
montréal l'étude clinique qui pourrait
permettre à suzanne de serre de gagner
du temps de survie va prendre du temps
elle reste donc réaliste alors qu'elle
vient de devenir grand maman il ya
quelques jours ce qui me fait beaucoup
de peine c'est de penser que je ne serai
pas de faits moindre mais qu'est ce
qu'ils vont faire ça j'avoue que le
coeur de maman et de grands moments et
c'est un petit peu un petit peu atteint
on me donne une date de péremption
alors moi je vis une minute à la fois et
chaque minute je m'assure que je suis
raccord avec ce pays j'en profite au
maximum
[Musique]